I don't think I don't like the word
requirement really in itself and I don't
think that's something like and I don't
really like the word community service
that much either because I think it
comes with the stigma of it's a
requirement to a lot of students and so
it doesn't seem like something that's
very meaningful or important it's just
like something that you have to do in
order to graduate so um but I do think
that there needs to be some sort of
requirement in some sense because a lot
of people otherwise wouldn't get
involved but it needs to it needs to
engage the students a lot a lot of
places where with schools have students
doing volunteer work it's mindless work
they don't have to think they go and
they sit in an office and they file
papers for however many hours they have
to do it in the minute that they get to
the last hour of their commitment
they're out they're done they're happy
and you know that's okay but it's really
that's doing nothing to build a movement
and it's not engaging the students at
all so if anything it really turns them
away from wanting to get involved with
things like this in the future so I
think that you know students should be
given an opportunity to choose what
issues they want to work on and and
that's why we always have the forums and
workshops about student leadership so
that they can learn that historically
students have been a huge part of every
single movement this country in this
world has ever had and that's not really
told in our textbooks very much you know
it's not really taught to us in school
that that's the fact that it really is
and I think when students see that in
the past students have been so powerful
in movements and creating social change
they're more likely to stay involved
with it now and especially if they're
working within their communities or
communities right near them on combating
issues that directly affect them I don't
see any reason why wouldn't kind of hook
on to somebody you know there are plenty
of people who will fade off and you know
this type of stuff isn't for them and
that's you know that's fine that's
everybody's personal choice but you know
we've seen that the more that we link
these issues to our communities the more
people stay involved and stay
invigorated and want to continue to do